using his body and chef against Tim be a
combine one of twelve shouldn't it
besides Jim Turner is Jack Tatum gets it
an offensive rebound shot clock goes to
14 seconds last year in the regular
season the Celtics took care of the
76ers three games to one
Tatum step back true then so far all of
one
she's smooth that's good look at the
flow here look at the bounce I mean this
has Colby Bryan written all over it
he puts the defender at a disadvantage
understands when the defender is off
balance and just raises up and knocks
down the shot
and you talking about just on the right
to the hands of Tatum Tate them off to
the races dangerous play here there's
got to be nine one
someone's got to see this potato
[Music]
Tatom for the Boston Celtics the two
minutes gone here on the burbs are ready
for block shots for Alice get is good
this kid is ready for part time
hey Sun Tatum parting the Red Sea with
the finish here not a blue jersey in
sight to phytate Oh
[Applause]
my king sent a number Hayden was licking
his chops the whole way down looking at
TJ McConnell he knew he was taking this
all the way to the rim
with the smaller McConnell comes Tatum
this man John McConnell will try to
exploit away a game understanding
there's no way McConnell is going to be
able to stay in front of Tate on the
Tatum is Dancing with indeed and then
beat is right with a look at the teeth
look at the Stephens by Joella be
against the table and it's going to fuel
a great rivalry between these two great
organizations Rozier
[Applause]
Hayward
[Applause]